[Musique]
je suis agricultrice sur une
exploitation de vaches laitières
je suis installé en production laitière
dans le massif central
[Musique]
la pac aujourd'hui représente une grosse
partie du revenu des agriculteurs
[Musique]
pour éviter que les capitaux des
exploitations partent vers de riches
investisseurs étrangers
[Musique]
pour éviter la volatilité des prix et
garantir des prix rémunérateur aux
producteurs pour aider nos jeunes
agriculteurs à s'installer
financièrement et pour la modernisation
de nos exploitations
[Musique]
la pac est fondamental sur nos
exploitations étant donné que le prix
des produits n'est pas rémunérateur pour
les producteurs on ne peut pas se
permettre une baisse de 20 mille euros
de notre venue il est impératif de
garder un budget fort et ambitieux de la
politique agricole commune
on ne peut pas se permettre de voir le
budget de la pac baissé
[Musique]